Hi everyone, in this lesson,
we're gonna do a brief overview of the Megascans tool
to be able to make layered textures
and some things to look out for.
So let's get started.
So to be able to make a blended material
using Megascans, you have to keep some things in mind.
One of them, you gotta make sure, of course,
that you do need to be logged into Quixel Bridge
and have the latest,
but also when you're working with your materials
to make sure the materials are the latest
or the newest type materials.
Now, the reason why, if I chose an older material
and to say, I've already downloaded it
and maybe it's inside of my system,
like, oh, you know, Megascans,
what do we have?
Megascans wise, I don't think I have any Megascans
in this particular example.
Oh, there we go.
And we have Megascans, we'll go to our surfaces here
and say, I got a coal mine.
If it is a older material
and it's paired with an also an older material,
these are both kind of old, the Clover ideal,
it would actually work pretty well.
But if I decided to go to a brand new released material,
say this one, it would be very difficult
to be able to get these and download them
and have them in my scene.
And then once they're selected,
get them into the blending
because the way they're structured from old to new
is very different.
The newer versions are a lot more efficient
in being able to customize the material.
The older ones, not quite as much.
And when you try to pair them together,
Quixel Bridge can get confused
and you'll see it here in the interface.
There's a little kind of like a bar
to be able to change values in here.
This used to be able to be a different setting
where you can actually control some more details
about what you're getting.
Now it kind of is turned into the button
that takes us to how to blend
and maybe switch a 3D master material and so forth.
So if you wanted to,
you would want to select a couple materials
that you would need
and you would say create a material blend
and you can do that through your content browser.
So I could choose maybe the clover here,
click on that interface again and say,
hey man, I'm gonna create a material that I want to blend.
Now you got to make sure that they are selected.
So I would have to like kind of make sure
they're in the same kind of folder or something.
That's actually nice
because then you'll know which ones you've blended
and you would select them at the same time
and then you would make your blended material.
So they need to be selected in your content browser,
clicking this interface
and then you will say collect, create material blend
and it'll put it, it will call it material blend
and it'll put it where you want to put it.
So you can create a folder for it
which should work just fine.
Now again, the caveat is just a reminder,
if you have a brand new, new surface material
like in this new surface category
and I have something old like this grass and clover leaf
that may not match up.
So when you try to blend them, you may get an error
and may just say it did it, but it's just blank.
I've had that, doesn't quite work
and I personally don't prefer this method
and I'll show you why
cause it really just does a fade
which can easily be done the old school way
or the new school way
and you don't necessarily need quick soul bridge
to do it for you.
So let me show you what I mean.
So I'm gonna click on this particular material.
I'm gonna double click on it, open it up
and you'll see that we have our wood
and clover already kind of blended together
but it's blended in such a way
that it just kind of fades into each other.
So I'll see that I have a layer base albedo color
that I can control and a few other things
but we also have base layer rotation angle
and normal strength so I can push normals through.
And you'll see here, even with the normals
it's really just fading into each other is all it's doing.
We can do the roughness here
if we wanted to pull in the roughness
from one to the other.
And it's really again, stacked in such a way
so that it's simply just fading into each other.
There's the UV control
and you can see that we can move one away
then the other middle layer normal strength
get that UV control back to zero
and that's really all it does.
It's nothing necessarily to write home about.
It's nothing you can't do on your own if you wanted to.
So it's really up to you how you build it.
I don't necessarily prefer this way.
We can even turn on the top layer here
but this is really how you wanna do it.
Now I don't have more than just one.
You can choose more than just one or two
and even add a puddle layer if you wanted to.
There's no spec for it to reach out for that in here
that's detailed in that way
but that's kind of how this system works.
Again, it's nothing you can't do
with the old system and the new system.
So I don't necessarily recommend it because again
it's easy to forget your old material
versus your new material
and you could run into that major hurdle.
All right, so that's it with this video.
I just wanted to point that out
that that option is there and some of those caveats.
In the next video, we're gonna start breaking down
how to create this type of layered material
which is our new way of being able to control
and create layered materials.
Thanks again.